[Music]
and leave elan alone use which I agree
with leave a man alone not a better
humanity because he slips and said some
dumb stuff for my keys new baby he's a
human you know what he's gonna get us
off fossil fuels he's gonna save
humanity it's like oh let him save dumb
[ __ ]
yeah every once in a while just ignore
just be like it's fine just let him save
us all he's gonna save all of us and
make our lives better and do people
forget that nerds are really socially
off yes exactly the ultimate nerd you
think Iron Man though they don't really
empathy they're wrong I'm like and it's
totally fine yeah I'm like just let him
save our lives and just say let them say
FAR's like once every week like every
nerd is like that I love I love you I
must I love them he could literally come
out be like Indian people are just
stinky and Dom and I'd be like it's cool
I can't wait to go to Mars it's cool
like I don't hear um submitted by
meatloaf was my spirit was a big fluffy
German Shepherd scared of everything
yeah Elon Musk and his girlfriend
unfollowed each other after drama with
Azealia Banks Wow does I mean they're
broken up that's what people are
assuming on Twitter they unfamiliar
banks once again I went on a one-on-one
with Izzy Lee on Twitter once she was
like going off on Zayn Malik and then I
jumped in who's a Moloch st. Monica's
the guy from One Direction are you
pretty happy when that happened
zena's I love Zayn Oh your friend what
was she saying what did you say what is
she we don't like weaves like briefly
talk to each other moves in through his
cousins and he watches my stuff Sothis
on so Celia was just going out for like
Indian people she's just saying the most
why like we're air hairy we stink
creators we parry yeah you know monkeys
like just saying the worst thing you can
say about Indies and I just called her I
was like yo like can he be funny I
forgot what it was I yeah literally I
was like this isn't even like funny
that's but I think that's pretty much
what I said I was like so I just rose
around like these were
the user funny but they're not I'm like
you're just and then she said something
to me that was really offensive about
like being hairy or something I'll say
she know what the [ __ ] you are
no this is like a few years ago but what
happened was like I did that but but
there's people that still stand for
Azealia Banks like who I feel like black
feminists Twitter just loves is the bank
still regard it's so funny that she
would use like racial epithets that were
used against black people that's what
I'm saying she's always complaining
about racism like you literally said the
most racist ignorant [ __ ] to Indian
people enemy and Zayn and it's like
don't cry if you're doing the same [ __ ]
like she's like you Indian people in
your [ __ ] nappy hair it's like fried
chicken yeah said something about like a
swamp and job like like the language I
speak Punjabi that's like you know a lot
of people are up a jumpring and she said
something about Punjab of the rivers or
something and I was like this isn't
accurate
it wasn't even hacker it's just like
it's just a sort of lazy and dumb that's
what I'm saying I'm like I'm like I'm
just mad howdy do your research yeah
Wikipedia's angry amazing you're dumb
yeah but her music is great like I love
music I love her we always talk about
here sigh sometimes you're either
separate the artist from the as you
should I always do yeah like I love her
music but I just think she's mine siggi
piece of trash and they just bumper
music old style still bumper music
Alana's a Lia and Grimes Grimes is
crying she looked different during the
girlfriend yeah this one this is came
out it's like a couple at the met color
you love Muslims I didn't look to eat oh
you love buzz it literally looks like a
Korean man that turned white he got like
surgery to become a white person he
looks [ __ ] Korea this [ __ ] yeah kind
of weird I have an uncle that looks just
like him so what's the drama plans like
two dollars swap me slippers in turn
yeah what was the drama with them so
Oh Elon like you were mentioning earlier
he's been saying some crazy [ __ ] about
Tesla like 20% or some [ __ ] like you
drop like his Tesla company has been
taking a hit because of the [ __ ] thing
he's been tweeting well I didn't want to
remove him for the board - yeah they
want to remove her for the board you
know he's the brains of it he said
something before that dropped six
percent - and then now drop public and
thing yeah so apparently you pay like
forty thousand to like Republic in
funding or something but it's like yeah
keep going up in people got really mad
everyone's like wow dear you and it's
like well you don't know where the money
went
and it probably went to like some
Republicans that are progressive because
there's progressive Republicans I need
money to like so many other things that
was just like a fraction of like it's
and then sometimes you gotta play
politics you have to be some people that
get something done that is gonna be
better for the greater good
the greater good you have to do some
things that people might not understand
and so I made solar energy into a box
this big if to power wait I don't
understand what's wrong with giving
money to the Republican Party like
people are treating Republican party
like it's the Nazi Party so I'm saying
it's like Kanye when he was like yo it's
like even chance they're still American
all black people are Democrats yeah
that's so you can't how can you how can
you just qualify the like one party or
another party like there's people there
there's a huge people that that feel
that minorities if they're not on the
left then they're backstabbers yeah to
me I don't it's like you can be Center
you could be moderate you can be what
you have to be lazy that independent
thinker and rightly this identity
politics is [ __ ] crazy mental
communists anyway so yeah and you know
what you're allowed to be you're allowed
to as entitled to think that Brad as
much as you want thank you so that's all
just been going on right so then Azalea
said that she was gonna be making music
with crimes and so she stayed over at
Elon Musk's house for the weekend trying
to wait for Grimes to stop because she
says coddling her boyfriend so then they
could create they can finish this one
song together and she also she also
posted these messages between the two
between Grimes and Azalea what were she
where Grimes
do that yeah that's the mistake he made
invite her to her house yeah
you don't invite crazy here home he's
never met her anything you turn a
background I'm curious okay so Grimes
told Azalea according to this here he
has a giant dick and then she was like
wow that makes em look good huh
like how giant she's like I don't know I
guess I could measure it
lol he'd be like what the [ __ ] he's
always like what the [ __ ] though it's
funny you guys are like and then adayla
says lol but you're skinny your coochie
is probably tight everything probably
feels big to you and then Grimes says
like he's so proper Old English but he's
very open-minded is it was like isn't
she South African and then Grimes says
but you know South African white people
from that era are like worst most proper
English people basically uh I thought he
was while Thornberry for the longest
says azalea brian says he has a fake
made-up accent and then azalea laughs
and then Gran's is like he's it's not
like South Africa and his family talks
South African he has a weird accent that
doesn't actually exist we're on it so
how big is his dick is it real but I
don't even trust roms if she's having
the so cosy I'm like she probably like
is either like you both got caught got
duped but it's Kitty coochie like a
[ __ ] and he's like I don't know god I
just want the cars of the McEwen's
better look how crazy should they
conspire look how low-key crazy both of
them conspire Daisy anxiety crazy and
it's like he's just like trying to fix
evens yes it was reported that he and
followed crimes cuz he was like made you
backstab me well not really cousin
everyone knows that has a big dick no
but it's backwards company big dick
makes her stocks dropped did he'll be
fine no it's personal [ __ ] and also as a
Lee was saying that staying in his house
was like the real episode of get out and
that exaggerated the government goood
the government is just trying to stop
all of this because he's making me
manager so [ __ ] I agree they're in play
I don't I don't believe anything she
says ma'am after being Irwin it's a
personal thing that stinky hairy
competition a [ __ ] lowbrow jokes
another thing she said to was how could
advocate against racism when you're
[ __ ] racist yourself Hillary she said
I saw him in the kitchen sucking his
tail in between his legs scrounging for
investors to cover his ass after that
tweet he was stressed and red in the
face he's not cute at all in person who
cares anything about what the working
yeah you can tell it's like you're
carrying about look yeah of course if
you're like your stocks are going down
you're gonna stress out you know I must
go look like a [ __ ] dumb I don't give
up okay he's [ __ ] smart
he's more handsome than the Alibaba dude
that looks ugly as [ __ ] how how
superficial this fool is he looks pretty
interesting he's like he just stopped
developing out there becoming a few it's
his face is too small for his head Jesus
Chinese billionaire he's the one that
like starting a body Baba
what Solly Baba it's like this site
where a lot of people got together
wholesale over and my China's on of
China oh this guy yeah yeah you see how
small is it looks like somebody
Photoshop is his face yeah he's like one
of the fastest-growing uh
billionaires but you know then that
means this brain just really dude
yeah this brain is huge what I don't
understand is why is he gotta be so
[ __ ] ugly dude it's not fair you know
what I mean
it's just now you're just sounding like
how are you different than her no no no
this is why I care okay cuz we want good
representation of Asians and it's just
so unfortunate that like I mean so we
have like a lot of rich billionaire
white dudes that are like that look like
like Elon and then [ __ ] Richard
Branson in his heyday and like context I
mean it's all beauty context no it's not
cuz Alibaba even in even in Asian terms
Jack Ma even in Asian terms he's not
beauty didn't
culture it's considered more beautiful
to be light-skinned you could be
beautiful and like beautiful like
symmetrical face and you have dark skin
you're instantly considered I think
that's everyone in yeah sure that's all
enjoy Mexican stew that's crazy
but that's beauty but even in Asian
standards that motherfucker's ugly as
[ __ ] there might be a crew out there
that loves money's mud
no small faces of big hugs Jack Maz face
legit yeah waiting the circle okay get
that there he's not gonna win amongst
these people Loki I think he's kind of
cute he's gonna this is what I see why
she his face it looks like this goal
with no meat on the inside and skin just
attached to it that's what it looks like
that's why it looks a little weird
everything pulsating like you know what
his head is like he's a smaller face but
his head so big and it's like if I was a
girl I would be like that be a good face
to sit on cuz there's so much room to
sit but the face is so concentrated
don't really care to sit on guys faces
you know what I'm not a girl I'm just
like right here from the internet I'm
just like oh that's what girls like
sitting on faces because everybody's
talking about sitting on faces see
that's the thing it's relatable his head
God Jesus dude you could head butt the
[ __ ] out of somebody
[Music]
[Music]